buenos días mi nombre es willy y estoy a
cargo de desarrollar el contenido de la
parte de ingeniería eléctrica de camp
academy y por aquí tenemos un tweet de
jane que nos pregunta nos podrías hacer
un vídeo resolviendo problemas de
circuitos complejos de física por
ejemplo un problema que tenga más de una
batería corriente simétricas etcétera
algo similar a la siguiente pregunta así
es que vamos a tratar de resolver este
problema y te voy a enseñar cómo lo
resolvería yo a ver echémosle un vistazo
rápido por aquí tenemos dos baterías lo
cual es un poquito inusual y luego por
aquí tenemos dos resistor es pero que
tienen el mismo valor 1.4 oms y luego
hay un tercer resistor conectado y lo
que nos preguntan es cuál es la
corriente en este registro de aquí y
esto es lo que estamos buscando y la
forma en la que yo resuelvo este tipo de
problemas es primero familiarizarme con
el circuito tratar de imaginarme cómo
fluye la corriente
y qué es lo que está sucediendo y una
buena forma de hacer eso es volver a
dibujar este esquema y de esa forma
permitir que mi mano y mi cabeza se
aprendan muy bien cómo está construido
todo este circuito así es que vamos a
empezar dibujando las baterías por aquí
tenemos dos baterías y como podemos ver
aquí están conectadas eso es bastante
interesante y luego cada una de esas
baterías está conectada con un resistor
y luego estos están conectados déjame
checar si están conectados y luego se
dan hacia el tercer resistor así es que
aquí simplemente quitamos todas estas
esquinas extrañas y puntos
simplemente volvimos a dibujar este
circuito pero con las típicas esquinas
cuadradas a las que estoy súper
acostumbrada y ahora le voy a poner
todos sus valores por aquí tenemos 11
volts y además sabemos en este símbolo
de batería que la línea corta es el
extremo negativo
a la larga es el extremo positivo y lo
mismo sucede por aquí
estas dos baterías están conectadas
exactamente en la misma dirección y por
cierto esta batería también tiene 11
volts lo cual va a resultar ser bastante
interesante pero bueno a esta
resistencia le vamos a llamar r 1 a esta
r 2
y a esta de aquí r3 y lo que estamos
buscando es cuál es esta corriente de
aquí pero bueno antes de ponernos a
hacer todo tipo de cálculos primero
vamos a ver si podemos simplificar este
circuito porque por ejemplo por aquí
estoy notando que tenemos un pequeño
truco observa estas dos baterías los dos
extremos de estas baterías están
conectados por lo que aquí tienen el
mismo voltaje aunque no sabemos cuál es
ese voltaje pero es el mismo para ambas
baterías y además las dos baterías son
de 11 voltios por lo que estos dos
nuevos de aquí tienen exactamente el
mismo voltaje ok porque los dos tienen
el mismo voltaje con respecto a este
nodo este nodo tiene 11 voltios menos
con respecto a este nuevo y lo mismo
este nodo tiene 11 voltios menos con
respecto a este nodo entonces tienen el
mismo voltaje
y es que lo que me voy a imaginar es que
voy a poner un cable entre estos dos
nodos porque como los dos tienen el
mismo voltaje que es 11 voltios menos
que este novo entonces como no hay una
diferencia de voltaje entre estos dos
nodos no habría corriente en este cable
ninguna corriente sería desviada de aquí
para que me viceversa así es que como no
afecta en nada del circuito de hecho lo
voy a dibujar así la corriente fluye
directamente hacia el resistor porque
absolutamente nada de corriente se va a
desviar en esta dirección y de la misma
forma toda la corriente fluye hacia el
resistor ninguna se desvía en este cable
porque sabemos que estos dos nodos
tienen exactamente el mismo potencial
pero bueno es momento de volver a
dibujar este circuito por aquí podemos
observar que tenemos dos baterías cuyos
extremos positivos están conectados y
cuyos extremos negativos también están
conectados
es que en realidad están funcionando
como una batería más grande vamos a
volver a dibujar este circuito se ve más
o menos así tenemos por aquí nuestra
batería combinada más grande y está
conectada con el resto del circuito y
vamos a volver a poner por aquí la
anotación para no confundirnos este sr1
este es r2 y este es r3 este circuito si
se ve más sencillo no y de hecho vamos a
seguir observándolo y simplificando
todavía más porque aquí podemos observar
que r1 y r2 están en paralelo tienen el
mismo voltaje de entrada y de salida y
eso significa que están en paralelo y
pues sabemos muy bien cómo simplificar
resistor es en paralelo sólo tenemos que
usar la ecuación de resistor es en
paralelo si tenemos todos resistor es en
paralelo digamos el resistor uno se
encuentra en paralelo con el resistor 2
la verdad es que acabo de inventar este
símbolo pero lo que quiero decir es que
estas dos rectas paralelas
quieren decir que estos dos receptores
se encuentran en paralelo y la fórmula
para dos resistor es en paralelo es
igual a r uno por r 2 entre r uno más r
2 así es que lo único que tenemos que
hacer es sustituir estos valores
ok y podemos ver por acá que tanto r 1
como r2 tienen el valor de 1.4 son
iguales y esto va a provocar una cosa
interesante no cree que las dos
resistencias tengan el mismo valor
cuando hablamos de resistencias en
paralelo tiene un efecto interesante
porque aquí entonces tenemos únicamente
un valor r que es igual a r1 y r2 por lo
que tenemos
r por r entre 2 r
r entonces podemos cancelar este con
este 2 resistor es en paralelo cuando
tienen la misma resistencia es igual a
esa resistencia entre 2 y ahora si vamos
a sustituir los valores
r es 1.4 oms 1.4 oms
entre 2 entre 2 que es igual a 0.7 oms
esta es la resistencia equivalente a
estos dos resistor es en paralelo así es
que estamos en un muy buen momento para
volver a dibujar este circuito tenemos
por aquí nuestra batería compuesta y
ahora en lugar de dibujar a los dos
receptores en paralelo voy a dibujar a
un resistor equivalente y luego por acá
tenemos el resistor r3 por aquí nada ha
cambiado y finalmente regresa se cierra
el circuito llegando nuevamente a
nuestra fuente de voltaje y ahora si
pongamos nuevamente la anotación este
resistor es 'el resistor r1 en paralelo
con el resistor r2 este de aquí es el
resistor r3 esta es la corriente que nos
interesa calcular y por aquí este es el
lado negativo este es el lado positivo y
tiene 11 volts
y ahora sí ya tenemos un circuito
bastante sencillo y aquí podemos
escribir los valores de estas
resistencias r1 en paralelo con r 2
tiene 0.7
r3 por aquí nos están diciendo que
tienen 2.7 oms 2.7
y ahora esto es tan sencillo que hasta
podría hacerlo yo en mi cabeza
simplemente tenemos dos resistor es en
serie y la ley de ohm nos dice que el
voltaje es igual a la intensidad por la
resistencia esta es la forma de la ley
de ohm de la que yo siempre me acuerdo
pero si lo que yo quisiera fuera
calcularla ahí es muy sencillo
ok y la iv es la corriente la intensidad
lo único que tenemos que hacer es
dividir entre r y nos queda que y es
igual al voltaje entre la resistencia y
ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es
sustituir estos valores así es que es
igual al voltaje que es 11 volts
11 volts / la resistencia pero estamos
buscando la resistencia de 2 resistor es
en serie y para encontrar eso
simplemente tenemos que sumar estas dos
resistencias porque están en serie o sea
que tenemos cero puntos 7 + 2.727 oms
así es que tenemos que calcular 11 entre
3.4 y eso
11 entre 3.4 es igual a 3.235 porque
esto es igual a 3.235 y muchos más
decimales pero la unidad de esta
corriente va a estar en amperes así es
que listo ya terminamos esta es la
respuesta nos piden que encontremos la
corriente
y ya la calculamos sabemos que la
corriente y es igual a 3.2 amateurs y
bueno de hecho podemos verificar cuál es
la respuesta correcta aunque porque
james nos mandó la respuesta la
respuesta correcta es 3.23 52 9 enteros
y así es que lo hicimos muy bien muchas
gracias por escucharnos